hey everyone
welcome
we are still in costa rica
we are now in the capital
san jose
we have reconvened
with two of the
pettino massaro shift into permanent
alignment
retreat attendees
we are now going to be sitting down with
fernando
uzaga and maribel piedra hello
hello it's good to be here
thanks for having me two beautiful homes
beautiful energy
thank you yeah we're happy to have you
reconvened yeah that's right
it feels really good it was actually
really interesting that i went on that
week long
exploration of costa rica in a different
energy right and then returning back
to this home
energy that was very much similar to the
container energy that was present
and created by the team
and the retreat was just it was very
ineffably home
yes felt so good yes
yeah so now it'll be exciting to be able
to
share your journeys like we've done with
several of the other attendees of the
retreat
so technically i actually said when we
interviewed hillary and gina that that
was the last
podcast right but who knew
we knew that a week later
that we would be doing the actual last
retreat
broadcast right great
lovely yeah me too
it's very interesting because it was not
planned at all
and so we're very happy to have you
at our home and that you feel
comfortable enough to do this podcast
with us
and yeah this is exciting
yeah yeah and also during the years
um my husband and i have been
making a conducive
space for us to be transforming and
becoming more and more light and love
for yes shooting for
the highest right right which is
awakening
right fully union we got
we're already that but
it's like knowing um
and experiencing that without all that
interference in that connection
perfect okay let's go
into exactly that how did
you we can even start with maribel's
sheets brought forth energy
how did you come to your
union with god how did you recognize
your true nature
i think it's something that we all have
you have it i have it he hasn't he has
it we always have it
we are born with that and for me
um
i i was sure
since i was very little that
there was a guy it took me a few years
to realize that god
was in me with me all the time
but when i was little i grew up like
in the outside of the like in the
countryside of costa rica so my
closest neighbor was one kilometer away
and i i used to
sit in a hill in a ranch and just pray
but the hill was like the highest spot
for me so i
since i was little i thought well i'm
gonna be closer and closer to that if i
zip
higher so i used to sit there and talk
with that like it was my
closest friend because literally it was
so for me it been just realizing that
it's not something that you experience
outside of yourself
but within yourself and
to be able to recognize it you just need
to
desire that and to drop all the
thoughts and just you're gonna find it
it's there
it's just that you forgot but you can
remember
it's all that you can do
beautiful
fernando yeah yes
um i have this um
recollections when i was a kid as well
that i would ask myself
what am i doing here just
what am i doing why i am here in this
world uh with this
bye something was
something was not clear for me so
i started that like
since i ever remember and then when i
was
10 years of age i
decided that it was too much for me
and so i had to kind of
put it inside of a file
and just put it in a file cabinet
until i i had more understanding
so that i could take on that again
and so i did that and for
for some years i just went down with my
life you know
adolescence and um and then
being a young adult i finished
i finished college and i when i just
finished college
it came to me that i had to make a
decision
like okay so this is it this is where
uh the rubber meets the road so to speak
i'm gonna take on this that i put in a
file cabinet
[Music]
and um so it was clear to me that i
could take the road
uh um like the regular road
you know um have a profession
have a family have kids or whatnot
or i could take the road less traveled
and look for that
was nagging inside of me
what am i doing here yeah
and so um i was
um i was at the backyard of my mom's
house
just sitting there i was around
24 25 years old
and i would just organically naturally
started to pray and i was not this
particularly religious person
and to me prayer was not
didn't have the importance that it has
now for me
but i just naturally started to pray i
started to ask
for help basically on my search
because i needed some guide you know
some
guidance as to where to go
what people to meet in order for me to
understand that basic question what am i
doing here
and so i did that and it all started
from there
i started to meet the right people that
would lead me to
into meditation so i started to
meditate i took some yoga classes
and so that started to open up my
emotional body and then i started to go
even deeper
and then
[Music]
i guess that that was like um
a huge start for me i from there i would
um
i would just um be
wanting to go even deeper and deeper and
deeper into that
question that original question and so
um until
until i have come to a point where i
would feel
that question is
has no answers with words but with
just being within
being here within and so um
yeah i went through meditations
spiritual paths and whatnot and i just
naturally ended participating in the
bentino masada's retreat and
here i am just
enjoying this conversation
i loved in what fernando was sharing i
really liked the
main question of
what am i doing here what is this all
about
and it's interesting that
that's not the first question taught in
school
right exactly
yeah mentally that's
the first question is the metaphysical
one yeah what is my true nature what is
the nature of reality
who are we why am i here these
fundamental questions
because that in a sense catalyzes
as is said in sanskrit atmo self-inquiry
into the nature of awareness into the
nature of consciousness into the
nature of reality right
so that alone what am i doing here
at a super young age can be a huge
catalyst for awakening
but then there's all this stuff that
happens which is this
i'm getting a lot of pressure by parents
culture society to put the question into
the filing cabinet and close it
and then just go into the machine and
get handcuffed into
all these systems that are very
indoctrinating into materialism and
infinity into form into time
and ego and separation
and contracted energy seeking peace and
happiness
externally all this type of stuff
and to liberate oneself from that
process as soon as possible
and to even create pedagogy
that enables children to never even
enter into the contracted finite
heroic separate energy in the first
place
is a main role of
our vision of igniting that global
awakening in the future
so that was really interesting and i
also
find that in what you both share
there's an aspect of recognizing that
there is something
that is happening that is divine that is
sacred that is transcendent
that you can in a sense commune with
that you can
remember your union with that
right and i love how you said several
times that
this is not outside of me
this is inside of me this is my
awareness
this is my heart and that that awareness
and that heart
is shared as that central intelligence
endlessly expressing itself creatively
so
maybe it would be good to
explore
how you became aware
of awareness itself
i want to go back to them please before
yes
because i think this is something
important i don't know if there are
parents that
look at your yeah podcast yeah for sure
and i think this is
very important as a mother for me to
share before
we both do the other important question
is like
the system the way that the system is
created and the education that the
children receive at
school it's like
they need to learn to look everything
in the outside they don't teach them
how powerful they are
they don't teach them they are enough
they teach them you fault your power
hand it to me and get into the system
and and it's important to help the
children
just to look within you know look within
in games they can look within
and the youngest they start the
easiest life and less often they're
gonna have
and if we have this information it's
important for me
to share that because i know that
we all have been part of the system we
all have been powerless
we all have feel like somebody is taking
this power away from me
nobody can take it away from you you
hand it over
and you can take it back it's yours
it was given to you by god so he's yours
your powerful being and
the children deserve to to keep it
i wanted to say that before that order
for answering that question yeah yeah
thank you
yeah it's important keep their innocence
you know they're so connected and we
start like
feeling them with you're gonna have to
have good grades you're gonna have to
have
to go to school you have to in this
country
even be catholic want it or not it's
something that is teach
in a school so there's
all kind of things are
like imposed to you since you're very
little and
and you can also give them the freedom
to the children to you know how it feels
to be within
close your eyes be within he will know
how to do it because it is ours
it's part of our true nature we know how
to be with it
that's how you get aware of awareness
how else
perfect great answer yeah
and it's also in childhood um
because we were talking about the
origins of that feeling
and to me also i i felt kind of
um i had the tendency to be on my own
as a kid so
yeah i had i had friends when i was a
kid
but i could
be on my own for hours and then then i
learned
that i didn't need to
escape from being within
and so i i would say that my first
experience
of aware of awareness
was when i was on my own as a kid
and i didn't know at that time that was
called meditation
you know i just didn't naturally and
i was lucky enough to have a mom that
would encourage me to do that she she
would respect
that i would want wanted to be on my own
in silence yeah and so and it was not
weird for her
for me to do that and so um
i guess that's that's very important
what you said because
um sometimes we as adults
feel the need of feeling or feeding
children's minds of stuff
just stuff just just because
and not respecting the fact that a
kid can be wanting to be on their own
in silence because it's something
natural
it's just natural to do that and then of
course then i realized it was
meditation and then i explored different
currents of meditation and whatnot
but to me it was it was that first
experience
of being on my own in science and
just
being aware that even though i was in
silence
i i was
witnessing something that i couldn't
locate in my body or anywhere else
i i couldn't find a location for it
i couldn't find the words to explain
that as a kid
but i would i would feel that
and i guess that was a nagging
force that that you know was always
coming back to that question what am i
doing here
yes yeah yeah
yeah the seeking impulse dominated
our lives to the extent at which
these 80 retreat attendees
gathered right because the impulse
dominated
their lives more than anything else was
that desire
to desire unite
with your true nature with source with
god
it is everything whatever
is put into that north star position as
the highest desire
which we just published an episode on
north stars
that then you galvanize your entire
time life resources everything towards
what's in that
transcendent noble aim position
and if self-realization reuniting
recognizing one's true nature is in that
position
you have a higher much much higher
faster
likelihood and trajectory in attaining
said desire yes
it's cool that for becoming
aware of awareness that
you both indicated the simple
recognition of rather than
as we are taught
going outside everything is outside
this cup is outside
then there's this there's this line of
perception so this is like object
this line of perception but
what is the i that is seeing
what is the seer what is the observer
what is the witness what is the
awareness itself
that's why ramana harsh and so many of
the other greats
talked about that very fundamental
question of what
is i and just going
really hard at that question
in itself will help you become aware
of awareness itself and then pierce that
available fail
so that's what is meant by going inward
in word rather than out
in in go back so far
as to where you hit your source
and and it's possible yes
it's totally possible you just need to
remember
undesired um focus on that
it's not something that you're just
gonna do this and
it's gonna happen if you don't have
desire but you can do this and it's
gonna fall
because you do have desire to know the
truth
right and when you experience truth is
something that is
you know is true nobody can take that
away from you
you know it it is and it doesn't matter
what happened around you
you know at least one thing
and that thing is you is that i
am because you already know
and nobody can take it away from you
yeah
and also now that we're talking about
desire
one uh recent understanding
a very important understanding for me
was
that i can always increase that desire
that i can do things so as
that i can increase that desire to know
the truth
desire for god's love because it's
inside of us
and so but sometimes that forgetfulness
and that um veil
that's uh between your desire your true
desire and that
you just increase your desire and you
can just pierce it
and just go for it and it's never ending
it's just it's just never ending
because you increase your desire and
then you realize
you can you feel more desire
at the same time and then you're
situated there
within in the i am
and you feel
that you can go further and further and
further and further
within and so in in that
wanting to go further further further
within
is what we call desire
yeah and also like a grounded example
is like like something very simple that
just occurred to me it's like okay you
want the ice cream
yeah you have desire for ice cream
and then you open the door and it's
raining
you have two options how much you want
that
ice cream are you gonna go and grab an
umbrella
or are you gonna say well maybe tomorrow
or another day
you know because in the same way that we
have
this desire there is also another part
that likes to occur procrastinate
procrastinate
the the things because we always think
as humans we think we have time
i'm not gonna die in the next 10 minutes
i'm not gonna die tomorrow
maybe i'm not gonna die in another 30
years
yeah but you don't know and you still
think that you have time
and then the when you realize
that maybe you have time or maybe not
your desire goes like i want it now
i want to move now what what can i do
how can i do it okay i want this
information
where can i go to get the information
where is my next piece of information
that i'm needing
how am i gonna obtain it
well we both end up in ventino's
um retreat which is fabulous
very deep very crude
i mean what i like about that retreat
the most is like
it just gives you some questions and
everything
you discover it by yourself nobody is
telling you
you need to take this and now i'm going
to teach you this other thing
and i'm going to watch you this way
nothing
is you with yourself finding your own
truth
true uraya and true god in you
and then never forget it how are you
gonna forget it
is yours
okay there's two really good things
there uh the first one
is this ice cream analogy right this is
really good it's super simple
yes very relatable uh how bad do you
want it
yeah it's raining the rain is the
obstacles in life
your brain is those obstacles they're
gonna come and they're gonna see they're
gonna test your faith how bad do you
want yourself realized
how bad you want to god realize source
realize infinity realize
because if you want it bad enough you
will go get an umbrella
right and you will walk through those
obstacles you will
face those great challenges overcome
them
and you will recognize that you were
wearing
the ice cream the whole time
one of the first to say it like 1300
years ago he said
that
i am in my village but i need a road to
my village
right right right yeah
right you go from room to room looking
for the diamond that's already around
your neck
right right and so
yeah the desire the desire though to
recognize the diamond already around the
neck
exactly to recognize that you are
already what you see that you are
already at home
yeah and then the second really
beautiful thing
was that
and mari's actually mentioned this
several times while i've
been here and even mentioned it to me at
the retreat as well
which is that there's something that's
so profound
about the unique
taste or style of union
that each one of us undergoes
and that's what's meant by the sufi
metaphysic
the unity of finding because every
single one of these
expressions of infinity has its own
unique
taste and style with the
gps callback function that then
undergoes a process of uniting so you
guys
experienced a good amount of miracle of
love
yeah and then also and so there's
there's a good mix of of
style right in your union right and with
me there's a
different unique style of union and with
one of the viewers there's another one
of
the other viewers there's a different
one and so that's what's beautiful is
that when you encounter
this many paths one end yes when you
encounter it
this very presence energy of the
fundamental
i am that eternal impersonal divine
sachitananda that nobody can take that
away from you
that is your unique style
of recognizing your true nature
and then that point
there seems to be this very
relaxing and expanding
from what wasn't more of a contracted
separate energy to
one that is more
type of energy
[Music]
is empowerment and
enlightenment right
yeah both components yeah
and the recognizing that it's um already
within you
that's that's here
rather than desperately
looking for it in the outside which was
my experience for an
amount of time
and then come to understand
this fundamental teaching that is
already in you that you
are already that
you know and it's it just opens
all this myriad of possibilities and
also you feel weightless
when you come to that when you come to
that
and you reside in there in that place
just weightless and
for me it was fundamental that shift was
fundamental
not desperately looking for god
outside rather
just start to recognize and start to get
rid of what i am not
to start feeling that that i am
is god and so um
it's just amazing it's just
it's just amazing yeah exodus 3 14
i am that i am yes
and luke 17 21
is the kingdom of god is within you
right
10 30 is i and my father are one
so you get all of these little asi
in the sanskrit tradition as well you
are that
i am that thou art that we are that
right as bending you said of the retreat
as well that this
is that
yeah but also if we like
wrap up the information that all that we
are sharing you go to
okay let's see basic distortions in the
human beings
the way that we have been educated and
why now we have to get rid of the
i am not like the basic
um this the system teach the children
they get a test they get a good grade or
a bad grade
they get let's say a battery
um they get the bad grade
so you are either idiot
not enough unworthy
of the of the
love or whatever validation
and that's key yeah because we spent the
rest of our
growing up life trying to find
how am i gonna feel myself worthy how am
i gonna
find recognition how am i gonna get
validation from others
how am i gonna find
happiness how am i gonna avoid suffering
but if you see it comes like
from that teaching of the children you
are not
worthy you are not enough
that's what you're not and then you
spend like
your good 10 years just getting rid of
those distortions and finding
finding within yourself your power
that you are enough that you are worthy
and that god never stopped loving you
you know the very basic
it doesn't matter what you do or what
you have done
you are worthy and enough of the love
of god period
it is how it is
so yeah the system
teach to look outside that you're not
working you're not worthy you're not
worthy you didn't do it good enough
now you're grounded so we start doing
all kind of things to avoid being
grounded
and if others recognize who i am
in the system i'm gonna call him the
system because i don't
i don't have a better word like to
describe it but
um the matrix of course it's the matrix
but i didn't know if you used that word
yeah we talked about numbers okay okay
like the matrix is
it's like okay how am i gonna control
this thing
how am i gonna what an easiest way
you know you you go to your first job
what what is what you want to do
like be the best worker ever so that you
can do
the next step and the next step and the
next step so
they teach you so well how to live in
the outside
that you just shoot for the outside even
god outside of you
yeah you're so hilarious
yeah that's such a great
i don't know it make me laugh it does
it's hilarious but sad at the same time
it's our own creation though yeah we
created
reality purposely to be confusing
enough to
make the process of seeking
what's already there
fun and playful and weird and
having different styles of coming to the
realization
it's so cool that there's an
in and out component to this
but the information all the information
is there
so we go back about desire all the
information is there
yeah you just need to decide the very
fact that there is an observer
in the reality is enough
in itself exactly
but but
but we're talking about how we have been
taught
through the metric system right
so even even the matrix
has clues for us
to find something that resonates with us
even even i don't know the
i like despair the holy father is that
how it goes in english
that that prayer by itself is super
catholic but it's so deep
it's beautiful it's so powerful
and and and then you go to i don't know
so buttons hindi
buttons and they're so deep
so even the matrix um
there are important
parts of purity of information
that is spread in the matrix so
you grab something whatever fits you you
know you don't have to believe this or
that this or that
but something can like wake you up
and once you wake up you just have to
increase your desire
and once you increase your desire
nothing is going to stop you
and you just have to be aware of
what is wanting to stop you
to wake up because that happens it's
like okay am i lazy
like a part of my distortion so i
don't do any effort to increase my
desire
like really to wake up am i looking hard
enough
what am i looking which are my
distractions
we all know what that is we all know
yeah
it's just that we play gun but that
doesn't work that much
yes
when we are honest with ourselves we
know
he started to say okay i'm gonna take a
break from this like he did when he was
little
but you can do that as an adult like
okay
right now i need to take a break from
this
i'm not gonna go out for the ice cream
because i don't want to have dessert
right now
but i'm gonna give myself the space to
just be stupid for
one day and and you're deciding that
you know which is okay
because you're deciding but if you're
just being stupid because
because you want to be stupid or you
don't know that you are
actually being a stupid thing because
you're unaware you're unaware
we're always stupid an
easy way to snap
out of confusion is to become aware
of observation itself
so becoming aware of awareness itself
will quickly snap you out of confusion
because experientially
direct experience communicates to you
the truth of the profundity of their
being a observer of their being
awareness self the very
fact that you are
and are experiencing a creation
is enough for you
to know that you yourself are
the engine
of what makes all of this possible yes
yeah yes good grandpa
yeah that was that was a good vocal yeah
yeah i was trying to
too cool to put that in words
in a simple way in a simple way yeah
more of a simple way
yeah we crushed it yeah
nice yeah thank you thank you yeah
love you guys
i'm so excited for what we do together
here
yeah yeah have a lot
of exciting stuff that's coming up in
costa rica
together and igniting the global
awakening
it's pura vida here yeah
yeah so wake up
we need you we have to do all this
together
yeah that's true that's true
thank you yeah thanks everyone for
tuning in we love you very much
super grateful for you we would love to
hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know how you feel
about what we discussed in the episode
if the conversation brought you value
give the video a like it helps the
algorithm also subscribe if you haven't
yet to the channel and share the video
with people that you feel like
it would positively influence thanks
again for tuning in to officially now
our last interview from costa rica
and we love you very much we will see
you all soon thank you
thank you
you